dans les pays du sahel les paysans ne
doute pas des changements climatiques
des lacs ont disparu des terres fertiles
il ya 20 ans sont aujourd'hui envahie
par les dunes le cycle des sécheresses
et des inondations s'accélère
on a les fréquences inondations qui se
faisait dans le temps peut-être tous les
dix ans où tout l'est tous les vingt ans
la ola pratiquement chaque année en 2010
nous étions au niger pour couvrir une
grande sécheresse qui avait été suivi
par des pluies torrentielles
les hôpitaux débordés d'enfants en état
critique de malnutrition
[Musique]
ouais donc l'enfant il est là il est
dans une autre passion de l'art
consciente depuis deux jours leur décor
si j'aime parce qu'il ne peut pas
respirer 2009
l'ancien état chrétien la petite barre à
tous ne pesait que 5,4 kg le poids d'un
bébé sain de trois mois mais il avait
deux ans elle est décédée dans la nuit
suivant notre tournage après des
souffrances inimaginables
si on voit globalement dans le monde
c'est vrai qu'il ya assez de nourriture
mais il y en a ici dans les foyers il
n'y en a pas à manger donc ça me choque
mais remet à ses inégalités
depuis cette famine des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants comme baratoux
continuent de mourir de faim chaque
année
après une autre mauvaise récolte tahirou
niandou qui a huit enfants se résigne à
quitter sa terre natale pour sauver ses
plus jeunes de la famille à l'intérieur
comme à bourg a
notamment
commenté
son village morizet important dans une
région qui avait la réputation il y a
encore quelques années d'être le grenier
du niger mais les sécheresses et la
déforestation ont provoqué l'ensablement
des terres
basses eaux
[Musique]
au 20ème siècle les grandes sécheresses
dans le sahel survenait en moyenne ou 20
ans dans les années 2000 c'était aux
cinq ans maintenant les récoltes brûle
dans les champs aux trois ans les
sécheresses sont beaucoup plus
fréquentes
c'est une faute sur toi
cet agronome formé à l'université de
montréal analyse l'appauvrissement des
terres fertiles au niger les nombreux
sécheresse ont éliminé le couvert
végétal il n'ya plus d'arbres pour
protéger les sols contre l'érosion
l'effet de la sécheresse et des
inondations ont fait en sorte que des
terres importantes sont lessivés ou
simplement envahi par le savent soit
venant d'un côté so venant de plus loin
du désert
la désertification galopante atteint
maintenant le fleuve niger au sud du
pays cours d'eau mythique qui abrite
encore des hippopotames le fleuve
permettait aux agriculteurs de produire
entre les récoltes de céréales des
légumes ce n'est plus possible
je ferai tout allemand est ensablée on a
créé un phénomène d'ensablement de ceux
de ce fleuve
avec des sécheresses et des inondations
beaucoup plus fréquentes la crise
alimentaire est permanente quand les
productions siège dans les champs les
animaux puis les enfants meurent de faim
dit wang
peu importe la nature de l'aide dit il
elle est la bienvenue car la récolte est
mauvaise yacouba se prépare aussi un
quitté son village et son pays pour
aller au burkina faso ou au bénin d'hab
quoi nous pouvons dire dans le noir
c'est noir et cino warner games logo
noir chinois la grèce et les banques
[Musique]
les plus vieux sont aussi restés
derrière dans cette région du nord du
mali autrefois très fertile en veillée
par le sable le grand lac regin a
complètement disparu la végétation et
les arbres ont suivi le bois qui reste
est coupé pour faire la cuisson
la rareté de l'eau provoque de nombreux
conflits entre paysans et éleveurs qui
doivent aller de plus en plus loin avec
leurs troupeaux pour trouver du pâturage
et de l'eau
entre éleveurs et cultivateurs dit il il
n'y a pas un jour sans conflit parce que
l'espace exploitable est restreint tout
le monde le veut non
les jeunes familles ayant quitté la
seule école de la région est à l'abandon
donc c'est une école d'à peu près 400
élèves
400 élèves se lavait de toute une
génération
une génération perdue
une génération préparer pour l'exode ou
bien pour le recrutement
c'est le choix impossible de millions de
jeunes africains restés dans un village
sans avenir et risquer de se faire
recruter par un groupe armé ou prendre
la route de l'exil traverser le désert
et la méditerranée au risque de leur vie
dans l'espoir d'une vie meilleure